hey guys it's the 18th of January and my
name's Jess and here's what's been going
on in video games first up a new report
from research group super data has
claimed that xbox one sales have reached
26 million Microsoft have officially
said they have nothing new to share
regarding Xbox one sales since Microsoft
no longer shares Xbox one sales figures
they added their main metric for success
is focusing on engagement super Dada's
information was published as part of a
report on the nintendo switch the same
report indicated that the ps4 has an
install base of nearly 55 million units
which is slightly above the most
recently disclosed figure by sony
earlier this month which was 50 3.4
million units when contacted by gamespot
to verify the figure in the report
Microsoft reiterated that December was
the biggest month ever for Xbox one
sales in the US and it was the top
selling console over the second half of
2016 it sounds like the nintendo switch
may be getting another zelda game after
the release of breath of the wild in an
interview with IGN series producer Eiji
aneema said I haven't been able to fully
use all of the new features of the
switch there could be the possibility of
another zelda on nintendo switch he went
on to say that while the core element of
zelda game play stays the same he
wonders how the game could be expanded
previously innumerous said that the next
to zelda game could be
multiplayer-focused similar to the
legend of zelda triforce heroes The
Legend of Zelda breath of the wild will
launch on march 3 on both switch and
we're finally a new business insider
report has claimed that the nintendo
switch won't support netflix at launch
the report which claims to source
information from Nintendo's kit Ellis
says that the system won't have many
multimedia functions at launch don't
plan to watch netflix on the switch for
instance the wii u and 3ds both have
netflix apps so it seems highly likely
one will arrive on the switch eventually
guess what have been in touch with the
publisher to get more details that is
everything I have
they do have the gamestop the stories on
Pokemon go and Ghost Recon wildlands and
i'll catch you again tomorrow